[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes à manta ville
pour assister à la 80e édition du
paris-nice la course au soleil partira
pour la treizième année consécutive
depuis les yvelines et comme vous pouvez
le voir le soleil est bien au rendez
vous aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
[Musique]
la première étape est une boucle de
159,8 km à travers les yvelines et le
val d'oise avec départ et arrivée à
mantes-la-ville la commune située dans
le nord du département accueille pour la
première fois de son histoire le départ
de la course au soleil on est
complètement ravi donc là effectivement
c'est un événement un événement sportif
et festif pour nous puisque ici on
organise donc derrière derrière moi donc
le village d'animations alors c'est
certes la première course silence qui
lance la saison cycliste la course au
soleil au soleil au soleil à mantes la
ville on est vraiment très très heureux
qu'est ce que ça va apporter une commune
comme mantes la ville alors évidemment
la ville va être mise en lumière c'est
la 80e édition du paris-nice la 13e fois
que sa part des yvelines et ça va
perdurer et donc le fait que ça parte
depuis depuis mantes-la-ville
aujourd'hui dans cette zone ce n'est pas
anodin c'est une zone qui est derrière
moi là qui fait 35 hectares qui va être
complètement développé avec à quelques
mètres l'arrivée le terminus du rer eole
donc toute cette zone va se développer
et on est vraiment de très très content
de mettre en lumière donc notre ville
c'est son axe de développement les
habitants a l'air ravi vous êtes ravi
également alors les habitants n'ont pas
l'air ravis ils sont ravis on l'a vu on
l'a vu déjà depuis depuis quelques jours
bien sûr on a quelques contraintes en
bloque la circulation on a le rer qui
arrivent donc il ya des rues qui sont
bloqués mais néanmoins ils sont vraiment
contents que la ville soit mise en
lumière et de profiter des animations et
d'être d'être au coeur d'un événement
aussi aussi renommées
même en cours avec une énorme vague
quatrième et septième temps
au total plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont rendues au tour du
village départ pour observer les
coureurs dans la foule on retrouve
évidemment des habitants de vente la
visite sans rappel événement vous
regarde le tour de france on les voit
qu'on les fasse dans les yvelines
c'est sympa de voir ça autour de chez
nous pour le coup je reste parce que
j'habite à mantes la ville et je suis
niçoise donc voilà très content d'être
là c'est un super événement pendant ta
guise franchement ne relève pas certains
ne se contente pas de regarder ils sont
venus avec un objectif en tête essayez
d'obtenir un souvenir avec les cyclistes
pour immortaliser le moment vous voyez
je me suis fait une petite fouille
je peux signer le courant j'ai des
collections depuis 18 ans qu'on fait du
passage des coureurs pour récupérer
quelques autres rares en suisse est
passionné de vélo donc on en profite
d'autres profitent de l'événement pour
faire du vélo entre amis le jour j le
paris-nice et un haut niveau annuel pour
cette bande de cyclistes nous on est
venu de de paris donc on est parti d'un
vélo ce matin lire voir le le l'étape
aujourd'hui par le départ de l'étape
et puis on va retourner au coeur ça fait
plaisir tous les ans on paie on vient au
départ
c'est toujours un évènement ou pas ce
départ depuis les yvelines voici sa puis
ça c'est cool parce que c'est un terrain
de vélo assez sympa donc pour se rendre
à chaque mois on arrive à faire des
boucs assez cool parfois on a l'occasion
de faire l'état pour lutter
la veille on attend même et là on est
venu pour le départ on a fait un moyen
de faire les 30 derniers kilomètres ça
c'est sympa la fin d'êta 4 le rendez
vous a également attiré un public
international dans cette commune
yvelinoise de 19 mille habitants avec
notamment des supporters colombien
cola company annonce six colombiens et
au lieu
d'appeler
trois différents légumes si on pense que
c'est la roma inopinément et nele midhat
après la présentation des cyclistes
direction la ligne de départ pour les
organisateurs parmi eux pierre bédier le
président du département des yvelines un
nouveau départ depuis les yvelines
qu'est ce que ça vous fait 13e départ
c'est le partenariat avec aso
l'organisateur du paris-nice et du tour
de france et c'est le plein soleil il ya
du monde les gens sont heureux joyeux ça
nous sort un peu déçu si
internationaux avec le drame ukrainiens
et des soucis sanitaires donc c'était un
beau dimanche beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui est ce que ça vous surprend
non le vélo est un sport extrêmement
populaire et en particulier dans les
yvelines qui comme chacun sait est le
département où on peut faire du vélo le
mieux anne ile de france peut-être pas
en france marne ile de france à caution
est ce que c'est une belle promotion
pour le vélo dans les yvelines c'est une
belle promotion pour le vélo et c'est
une belle promotion pour les villes
c'est d'ailleurs l'objectif pour mantes
la ville pour son mr sami d'énergie pour
la population manque la ville c'est un
moment de faire découvrir leur ville
c'est un moment de fierté c'est un
moment de joie donc c'est superbe
un partenariat qui devrait durer au
minimum jusqu'en 2025 le département
voudrait conserver cette course au
soleil delà de cette date une envie
partagée par les organisateurs on est nu
ou très satisfaites
de notre partenariat avec le département
des yvelines depuis maintenant 2010 avec
le dimanche ce système de boucle on
repasse par des villes à forte
population pour repartir plus dans des
territoires ruraux le lundi matin mais
oui bien sûr ça fait toujours plaisir de
voir du monde de voir des sourires de
voir des gens contents il ya une vraie
aspiration à revivre comme avant bien
évidemment qui nous touche tous au delà
du cyclisme et ça s'exprime là ce matin
sur paris nice et c'est agréable en
effet après un peu moins de 160 km de
course et christophe laporte le français
de jean bovis maquis s'imposant cette
première étape yvelinoise devant ses
coéquipiers roglit chevaux nerthe la
première de sa carrière sur paris nice
je m'attendais pas du tout j'ai vraiment
du rapport mais bon là je suis vraiment
heureux
deuxième jour sur ce paris-nice 2022
aujourd'hui le départ est donné depuis
la petite commune de port- jce 2000
habitants direction orléans pour une
étape de 159 kilomètres
[Applaudissements]
à mes côtés daniel bon tu le maire de la
commune d'auffargis alors daniel bon tu
es ce que c'est un plaisir de recevoir
pour la première fois le départ du paris
nice c'est un plaisir c'est une fête
c'est un grand moment et que regarder
voire
magnifique on a le soleil oui le soleil
s'est pas toujours le cas sur un départ
de paris-nice est ce que c'est un petit
plus quand même pour vos administrés
c'est un énorme plus parce que s'il
était tombé des cordes vous imaginez un
petit peu alors que là on a beaucoup de
chance ce fabuleux on a le soleil c'est
la course du soleil donc le soleil est
au rendez vous au fort j et qu'est ce
que ça apporte à une petite commune de
recevoir le paris nice un moment de fête
comme je le disais c'est vraiment un
moment exceptionnel parce que toute la
population a joué le jeu et puis j'ai la
chance d'avoir une grosse équipe de
bénévoles qui nous ont beaucoup aidés
parce que ça nécessite quand même de la
station du barrage et autres et donc
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment un bon
moment de fête on met combien de temps
pour organiser un paris nice dans sa
commune
entend pourrais pas vous dire quoi en
temps cumulés mais ça fait un mois qu'on
en parle et tous les jours on fait un
peu attention et puis plus on avance et
plus il faut il penser ne rien oublier
voilà c'est une belle visibilité aussi
pour la commune oui c'est sympa c'est
super qu'on parle un petit peu d'eau
fort j'y suis ravi est ce que vous avez
senti l'effervescence monte au fur et à
mesure des semaines depuis l annonce on
le voit derrière il ya beaucoup
d'enfants ils ont l'air ravis alors dans
le village pour le vide agit non plus la
joie non les enfants qu'ils sont ravis
je suis content pour eux parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya une belle animation pour
eux et j'espère que ça va être aussi
pour eux un grand moment de fête
[Musique]
aujourd'hui nous sommes de la vallée
heureuse donc c'est formidable ça va
faire des belles images une belle
compétition c'est parti sur les chapeaux
de roue hier donc tous les ingrédients
sont réunis pour pour qu'on ait un grand
paris nice savez quand on part sur de
bonnes bases généralement on finit sur
de bonnes bases également donc ça donne
le ton pour la semaine qu'est ce qui
vous plaît dans cette petite commune de
faris ce qui me plaît déjà je la connais
parce que je la reprends ta c'est
souvent à vélo et puis encore une fois
le le cyclisme doit aller partout on
doit aller dans les petites communes on
amène des champions notre stade c'est
sur les communes dépit de communes donc
les champions viennent danser stade là
donc c'est merveilleux et puis moi on
est toujours bien accueilli bien
évidemment est ce que c'est le côté
populaire du du vélo du cyclisme qui
rejaillit quand on vient ici pour un
départ et sa balle côté populaire oui
forcément parce que quand je lui disais
tout à l'heure le manque aux sports se
déplacent partout et donc on doit on
doit on doit apporter les champions dans
l'un de ces petites communes là les
spectateurs sont là les spectateurs qui
ne voit jamais ses champions donc on les
retrouve ici aujourd'hui et vous savez
dans la vallée de chevreuse une culture
cycliste beaucoup de gens pensent que
cette vallée à vélo et je crois que
c'est la seule course aujourd'hui
professionnel qui parle dans la région
parisienne de paris femmes de paris ou
dans région parisienne donc on redonne
un petit peu toutes ces valeurs qui ont
été créés dans la vallée de chevreuse
avec antiga auparavant avec avec toute
cette histoire du cyclisme 7 vallées
donc aujourd'hui c'est un point
important pour nous
[Musique]
le départ d'une course est aussi
l'occasion de découvrir à les vélos les
bus des équipes et surtout d'approcher
les coureurs pollution très beaux ils
sont en carbone j'aimerais bien en avoir
un mais bon mes moyens me le permettent
pas ça c'est sûr
déjà la technicité quoi les dérailleurs
électriques sans fil les choses comme ça
que maintenant c'est impressionnant quoi
c'est vrai que c'est un peu petit trouve
c'est bizarre ça fait bizarre c'est un
petit peu petit mais vraiment ils sont
magnifiques la csa donne envie de rouler
avec quand même des très beaux vélos et
on voit qu'ils ont tous sont tous des
casettes ils sont tous ont toutes un
dérailleur électrique on voit que ils
sont à la pointe de la technologie au
niveau vélo
moi il ya des choses que j'aime pas
voyez c'est les freins les freins à
disque je suis pas j'ai plutôt vieille
génération par rapport à ça ce lundi 7
mars il ya plusieurs centaines de
curieux présents dans ce village
illinois je suis aux côtés de jackie un
supporter un fan de cyclisme et vous
êtes du coin aussi bas j'habite en
eure-et-loir mais justine et hassad
arnoult dans les yvelines et voila quoi
j'ai pratiqué un pôle cycliste en étant
jeune donc bah ça se perd pas on vient
voir un peu
c'est dans les gènes quoi et vous venez
tout le temps tout le temps je viens
tout le temps war paris nice je fais des
étapes du tour de france et bah on est
on est on est dedans donc on vient est
ce que ça vous choque ou ça vous
surprend ce côté populaire on voit qu'il
ya énormément de monde aujourd'hui non
ça me choque pas et puis et puis c'est
pas comme moi c'est gratuit 1
la route c'est pas comme le foot voilà
c'est ça le truc est ce qui est aussi
intéressant c'est qu'on voit des maisons
juste derrière une maison d'un de vos
amis d'ailleurs assez un ami qui habite
juste derrière laquelle on a travaillé
ensemble pendant plus de 30 ans dans la
même usine et au rock et la proximité il
ya les maisons il ya les cyclistes qui
sont juste à côté le maillot jaune va
être à deux pas de sa maison bien sûr et
puis ça gêne personne 5 et bien ses
spectateurs ont pu voir le premier
maillot jaune de ce paris-nice 2022
christophe laporte tout heureux d'être à
l'honneur ce jour là auffargis
way maintenant je réalise
ag
c'est dur à quand je voyais les photos
étaient encore en cours hier sur
le départ était donné à 12h15 précise
direction orléans les cyclistes du
paris-nice reviendront l'année prochaine
pour une nouvelle édition dans les
yvelines